[Music]
at a certain age for many their body
starts feeling like it's falling apart
medications pile up doctor's
appointments fill the calendar aging is
inevitable but what if it wasn't great
news about aging that probably most of
us don't know is we actually have a lot
more control over the aging process than
we think
let's take a look at the latest science
and how it might be possible to slow our
own aging
[Music]
according to dr levine's upcoming book
true age we have two ages our
chronological age the one we celebrate
at our birthdays and our biological age
our body's lifespan
biological age can be defined as the
state of decline or the state of
divergence that your body has undergone
as a function of time
lethargy graying balding wrinkling
dementia playing bingo we know the
symptoms of aging but what causes it as
we age our cells change a lot of their
states and they can actually transition
to different kinds of cells one type of
cellular state is what's called
senescence various types of cells can
convert to this and a lot of people
refer to senescent cells as zombie cells
that's because these are cells that due
to some stress
basically lose the ability to
proliferate or to make copies of
themselves so they're no longer going to
generate new cells at the same time
these cells are resistant to death when
cells undergo some damage one way to
prevent cancer is that damaged cells are
just going to commit suicide and be
taken out of the body but senescent
cells they remain in the body so they're
not
dead but they're also not proliferative
so this is why people refer to them as
zombie cells
wait aging might be caused by zombie
cells within our own body
some people believe that senescent cell
accumulation is the main driver of aging
that this drives the inflammation that
we see with aging which ultimately is
driving the dysfunction that arise
throughout our bodies it's still
debatable whether senescence is truly
driving it but there is some interesting
experiments giving some evidence to this
so people can actually take cells and
have actually injected them into mice
and what you see is that this actually
can shorten the lifespan of a mouse
they're constantly excreting a bunch of
row inflammatory cytokines and also
growth factors they can also make the
neighboring cells prone to becoming
cancerous as more and more of these
senescent cells accumulate in tissues we
see a lot of tissue dysfunction people
think that this is actually contributing
to various age-related conditions that
we see
the average 30 year old chronologically
is probably 30 years old biologically
but you have some distribution where you
have probably about half of your 30 year
olds are going to be older biologically
than they are chronologically and
another half which is younger
so how can someone find out their true
age their biological age scientists have
defined what we call hallmarks of aging
molecular or cellular changes that we
see tend to track with the aging process
there's two different types of data you
can use to estimate your biological age
one might be your clinical data the
basic lab tests that you might go get
from your doctor's office
this is basically what you're getting
when you have a yearly physical and the
doctor screens your cholesterol thyroid
and glucose levels so you would get back
your results and you could input it into
online calculators that are already
available biological markers are one way
to get a sense of a person's biological
age what's another test one that my lab
actually studies called epigenetic
modifications this is not changes in the
dna sequences song it's the activity of
genes that's something that's happening
on top of the dna so it's basically
turning off or repressing certain parts
of the genome while activating others in
2018 we developed one of these
biological age measures based on
epigenetics we measure
the amount of these chemical
modifications at very specific sites on
your genome to actually give you your
biological age
so an epigenetic test is different from
clinical blood work tests epigenetics
measures the stuff attached to specific
locations throughout your genome and by
looking at this pattern we can say to
someone whether they have the biological
features of someone who is actually the
same chronological age as them or
hopefully like someone younger than them
we developed an algorithm that could be
used to predict biological age as
accurately as possible now this is
available to consumers you basically
have this tube
here that you would spit into fill it up
to the line and then put it back in the
box and it actually ships to a
laboratory that's going to extract your
dna and measure these chemical
modifications to your dna run it through
the algorithm that we developed and in a
few weeks you get an email saying here's
your biological age
but the trillion dollar question for the
medical industry is can we reverse aging
in a benjamin button sort of way can you
actually take people who have aged and
actually revert them back to a healthier
state right now there is not
cutting edge science for changing your
biological age it's really what your
mother grandmother father told you don't
smoke drink moderately get a lot of
exercise although not excessively sleep
in terms of your quality of sleep but
also get enough sleep and try and
maintain low levels of stress from day
to day but there's a lot on the horizon
in terms of what the scientific field is
discovering maybe in the next decade or
two we might have therapeutics to slow
the aging process
remember the zombie cells from earlier
that many believe drive aging one
approach centers on removing senescent
cells from the body
scientists have been really determined
to try and target and remove these cells
there's actually a new class of drugs
that scientists are testing called
synalytics which actually target what we
call the achilles heel of these cells so
the fact that these cells are resistant
to death so this is an upregulation of a
certain pathway they actually target
cells that have this upregulation kill
them and then they get removed by our
immune system that sounds like an idea
still on the horizon what about a secret
fountain of youth hack for today as of
right now there's no secret hack there
are places throughout the world that we
call blue zones which are these regions
or hot spots of longevity places where
you have a much higher proportion of
people who survive to at least a hundred
these places are kind of scattered
throughout the world there's one in the
united states called loma linda in
california and people aren't sure why
these blue zones exist perhaps these are
areas where people have better health
behaviors or perhaps even less stress
there are definitely these shared
nutritional habits of these groups
however it hasn't been definitively
shown whether these factors are directly
responsible to the longevity advantage
we see in these populations what about
dr levine has she tried to intervene to
slow her own aging
i have measured my biological age
repeatedly over the last year i ended up
being younger biologically than i was
chronologically but given how much
effort i put in it wasn't really where i
wanted it to be so now over the next
year i'm really making an effort to be
much more rigorous to see if i can
actually figure out how to get that
number even lower we all know what our
lifespan means right it's the amount of
time you're going to be alive but more
important than lifespan is something
that aging researchers call health span
the amount of time in your life but
without any disease or without the onset
of the physical impairments that tend to
be associated with aging but when we
talk about intervening in the aging
process
this is what we're actually trying to
extend we don't want to just keep people
living longer in an unhealthy state we
want to keep them living longer in the
healthiest state possible for as long as
possible
you